- [Lecturer] We're told
an electronic circuit
has two resistors with
resistances R one and R two
connected in parallel.
The circuit's total resistance,
R sub t or Rt is given by this formula.
Suppose we increase the value R one
while keeping R two constant.
Does the value of R sub
t increase, decrease,
or stay the same?
So pause the video and see if
you can answer this question.
All right, now let's work
through this together,
and some of you might be familiar
with the idea of an electronic
circuit and resistors,
and what they represent,
but you really don't
need to understand that
in order to understand what's
going on in this expression.
There's some quantity, R sub t,
that's equal to 1 over,
and then in the denominator
we have 1 over R one
plus 1 over R two.
So if we increase the value of R one
while keeping R two
constant, what happens?
So this is going to increase,
and R two is going to be constant.
So one way to think about it,
we have two variables here,
especially in this denominator,
but really, in this entire expression,
but if R two is going to be constant,
we really just have to
focus our analysis on R one.
If R two is constant, that
means it's just a number.
It could be two, it could
be five, it could be pi.
Whatever, but that is not going to change
as we increase the value of R one.
So let's think about
what's happening here.
If R sub 1 increases,
then what does that do to 1 over R one?
Well, if you increase the denominator,
then you're going to decrease
the reciprocal of that.
So that means that this
whole thing right over here
is going to decrease.
Now, if 1 over R one is decreasing,
if 1 over R one is decreasing,
what's going to happen to 1
over R one plus 1 over R two?
Will this entire expression
increase or decrease?
Well, this part is staying constant.
R two is constant.
So 1 over R two is constant.
Just imagine, R two could be two or three.
So this should just be 1/2
or 1/3 or whatever it is,
while over here, this part of
the expression is going down.
So if you're taking the sum of two things,
one part's going down,
the other part's constant,
then that means this whole
thing is going to be going down.
So the entire denominator
of this entire thing is going down.
Now, if the entire
denominator is going down,
if 1 over R one plus 1 over R two,
if this whole thing is going down,
what's going to happen to
the reciprocal of that?
1 over 1 over R one plus 1 over R two.
Well, if something is going down,
the reciprocal of that is going to go up.
If you get smaller and
smaller denominators,
1 over that is going to be
a larger and larger value.
So the value or Rt increases
if R one increases and R two is constant.
And for those of you who
know about resistance,
which is really how well
a current can flow through a circuit,
that will also make intuitive sense,
but you don't need to
understand resistance
to analyze this mathematically.